uh in the last few minutes police have
said that two football fans have been
arrested after a pitch invasion
following manchester city's title
triumph at their home stadium yesterday
police say the two men have been bailed
ahead of court appearances uh becky has
more for us hi becky tell us more
yeah we've just heard from greater
manchester police that two men have been
charged as you said philip maxwell has
been charged with throwing a missile at
pyrotechnic and paul colbridge has been
charged with going onto the pitch and
both have been bailed ahead of court
appearances and the police say inquiries
into a reported assault of a player are
ongoing that's that assault on villa's
goalkeeper robin olsen yesterday man
city have apologized to him they and the
fa are investigating the incident and
man city have said when they do find out
who that fan was he or she will receive
an indefinite stadium ban now villa
yesterday said that olsen is completely
fine but took a bang on the back of the
head and yesterday said they considered
the mata closed and wouldn't be pursuing
a complaint man city fans invaded the
pitch yesterday at the final whistle it
was a celebration they had banners and
flares but also ugly scenes not just
that attack but they were also seen
sitting on top of the goal and they
actually broke the crossbar and players
had to be escorted off the pitch and
what happened yesterday was just the
latest uh pitch invasion they've been
several of them at premier league games
recently raising questions about how
safe players are on the pitch and
unfortunately for man city fans and the
club yesterday's events have
overshadowed what was a remarkable
comeback for city uh they were two nil
down to villa with just 20 minutes to go
and managed to score three times in just
five minutes seeing off the competition
from liverpool and being crowned
champions of england once again they are
having an open top bus parade throughout
the city this evening at 6 p.m with the
team but you know as we've said all
these events from yesterday the fallout
from that pitch invasion that is all
hanging over the celebrations okay thank
you